( intro music )
This is the Great
Bear Rainforest.
This is a place on the
British Columbia,
Canada coastline.
And this is one of
those unique places
where you can be sitting in a
boat and you look at the land
and you can watch a bear
and a wolf on the beach
and you look around
and there's a humpback whale
and orca in the water.
This is one of those
incredible rare locations
where a wild landscape
still meets the wild ocean.
Those places have
largely been relegated
into the history books.
This is also the only
place in the world
where humpback whales sing
on their feeding grounds.
And this is what their
songs sound like.
( whales singing )
So, I first went to the
Great Bear Rainforest in 2010
on an expedition
organized by the
International League of
Conservation Photographers
to document the
bio-diversity of this area.
Why?
Well, because tragically
there was a proposal to put
an oil pipeline that runs from
the Alberta Oil Sands all the
way to the Pacific Ocean
and then have large supertankers
travelling through these
sort of remote fjords and
channels to take
the oil to Asia.
And the Gitga'at First Nation,
who are the local stewards
of this coastline had
invited us to help them
try to raise awareness
of that realm.
It's a rough coastline, it's
not a place for tankers.
And in my mind, you know
it's not a question of "if"
it's a question of when
a spill will occur
if these tankers do
move into that area.
It's just this incredible,
incredible wild place.
Published in
2011-2012, and, uh
that was not the
end of it for me.
I was hooked by this place.
I think I went back three
seasons in a row, on my own.
Working with local NGOs and
the Gitga'at First Nation's.
And for me the terrestrial realm
had been documented very well.
But the underwater world, by and
large, was completely unknown.
So, I went there to
try to, you know
really create a exhaustive
portfolio of life in the seas
of the Great Bear Rainforest.
This is the cradle
of kelp evolution.
Nowhere else on Earth are there
that many species of kelp.
It's a cold, it's a
nutrient rich sea.
Highest diversity of starfish
in temperate waters.
This is a Sunflower Starfish.
They grow to this sort of size.
They are the largest shallow
water starfish in the world.
You know, three-four kilos,
incredible predators.
But for me, the one
species that screamed out
pulsating life were jellyfish.
And in the right months of
the year, in the fjords
they aggregate in incredible
numbers to spawn.
Smacks of jellyfish, that I
just learnt a few years ago.
It's not schools, it's a smack.
This is basically me,
I've turned the camera
around on myself
and I'm now trying to
basically swim into
the densest part of
the jellyfish school.
Don't ask me why. It's just,
it's just one of those things.
They are caressing me.
I'm being tickled by jellyfish.
I think I get a little
jellyfish hat now.
There you go.
I've got a cap there.
Water is cold, it's
four, five degrees.
Every hour I climb on
the boat with my elbows
because I can't feel
my hands or my legs.
I kind of just, you know, like
a seal of shimmy
out of the boat.
I have this hot water hose in
my wetsuit for 10-15 minutes
lying on the swim
platform, like
you know, crying
and shivering.
And I do it three or four
times a day, you sleep
-really, really, really,
well on--
-( audience laughter )
In the Great Bear Rainforest
the one species that is more
important than any other
if there can be such a
thing, is a salmon.
Now once a year these fish
abandon their life in the ocean
and they move in-shore and
they swim up rivers to spawn.
I arrive at this one pool,
right below a waterfall
and I found this
little side chamber
this little sort of
nook in the corner
and I kind of wedged myself
in there and I waited.
Five minutes, ten minutes,
20 minutes, 30 minutes.
I think it was about 45 minutes
later that one fish came back.
( audience captivated )
And then another one came
back and then I just waited
like a, you know, I couldn't
move anyway, I was too cold
so I wasn't going to scare them.
And then I got
-this picture.
-( audience gasps )
So, all these fish just kind
of huddled together waiting to
pretty much take on these
mighty, mighty waterfalls.
I also, though, wanted an image
that illustrated the connection
that a lot of the wildlife
has with these salmon.
And I had dreamt up this
picture of a split-level.
Which is half underwater,
half above water.
Underwater you have the salmon,
and above you have a bear
with the salmon in its mouth.
And the waterfall flowing
by with a rainbow
running diagonally
across the frame.
( audience laughter )
I sketched my pictures and
that's what I sketched.
Very rarely do I get my
sketches, but,
you know, dream big.
And fail spectacularly.
( audience laughter )
Anyway, black bear
expert fisherman.
He's waiting, he's waiting
and he has got one.
I watched this bear for
hours, he had this technique.
And once he gets one, he walks
up into the forest, eats
and every 15 minutes, he comes
back down he gets hungry again.
He gets another one.
He disappears and
now he comes back.
In the meantime, I
snuck into the water.
And he's just not sure.
You know, this is "bear
snorkeling 101".
( audience laughter )
The bear can smell you even
if you're in the water.
Something I learned.
I'm trying my best, I'm
sneaking up to this bear.
I can see the salmon underwater.
I have this picture in my
head and I try and I try...
Every time I get past
this little area
right about now he spots me.
-He was like, "I got you!"
-( audience laughter )
"I see you, you damn National
Geographic photographer!"
( audience roaring
with laughter )
And it's just like, and I go
"Okay, fine, I give up, man,
alright, alright." Plan-B.
If I can't get a picture
of a bear and a salmon,
let me get a picture
of a salmon leaping
from the bear's perspective.
And I have timed this.
I have 15 minutes before
the bear comes back.
So, I sit where the bear sits.
And I got pummeled with salmon.
-Now... this hurts.
-( audience laughter )
And you know, I had bruises.
But again I'm more worried
about flash placement.
Every time I place the flash
they hit the flash again.
And so, complete disastrous,
disastrous mix of things.
( sound of waterfall )
And it's like the shotgun,
they come in waves.
Bang, bang, bang, bang, bang!
And there's one frame
that I kind of like,
and it kind of, sort of,
you know, connects...
I wanted a picture that connects
the salmon with the forest.
And this is what I got.
( audience gasps )
"Salmon in the
trees", I call it.
( audience laughter )